what artists can do is help us look at
data differently and find alternative
ways of thinking about it whether data
is this endless box of LEGO pieces that
arise everyday it's always a different
box and it allows me to again and again
build things out of this information to
try to understand it in a
three-dimensional way my name is
nathalie neva I am a sculptor I
translate science data into woven
sculpture I start by gathering data
either from my own instruments or from
the internet it's not just temperatures
wind environment pressure it's all these
tentacles all these human stories that
are connected that really make this
information so rich the method that I
use is basket weaving because basket
weaving is a very simple three
dimensional grid that I can use to
translate data with
everything in a sculpture whether it's a
colorful bead whether it's a string
whether it's a dowel or whether it's a
reed represents some sort of data point
so nothing is put on there for purely
aesthetic reasons so this is the band of
hurricane grace again these are all time
Bend so you can see at 6:00 p.m. we had
a southwesterly wind it's important to
me that these pieces are actually very
accurate because I want them to live in
the science world as much as in the
sculpture or in the crafts world I still
want you to be able to read the weather
off of these sculptures like 8:00 a.m.
we had 28 foot high waves and the storm
was coming from the southeast weather is
this invisible complexity that we walk
through every day we can't see whether
we can feel it we can smell it we can
taste it but you can't see temperature
you can't even see when all right I
think it's so important in helping us
understand data better
you